hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar using single cell multiomics to
accelerate cancer immune cell therapy
research i'm susie valdez of labyrinth
and i will be your moderator for today's
presentation
now i'd like to invite everyone to
participate by submitting your questions
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
just click on the question mark icon on
the left toolbar
for further help or submit your concerns
in the ask a question box so let's get
started today's webinar is presented by
dr adriana suarez science and technology
advisor at 10x genomics in this role dr
soares helps researchers adopt single
cell and spatial technologies to address
their scientific questions for a
complete biography of dr adriana soares
please click on the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr swords welcome you
may now begin your presentation
well thank you for the introduction
susie and thank you everyone for joining
us today uh we are going to be talking
about how single cell museumics is
helping us tackle these very tough
questions that we have in cell therapy
research so we have a lot of promise but
we also have fundamental questions that
we need to address so hopefully in this
talk you will you will get a view of how
these single cell technologies are being
used
for cell therapy discovery and and
development
so first i wanted to give you an
overview of the field basically the
state of the art and i wanted to start
with this quote from sam hattie uh an
oncologist from the fender institute he
compares the technology of single cell
with a microscope how these platforms
are giving us a whole new lens into life
and biology and it's giving us a new
instruction manual so we can leverage
that to really tackle these tough
questions that we have in different
biological and scientific fields and of
course the topic of today is cell
therapy research
in terms of what has happened in recent
years i wanted to give you an overview
of some of the highlights
um so in 2018 science highlighted a
single cell as the breakthrough of the
year and this was more about the
applications how people and different
research groups were using or are using
these technologies
to explore uh heterogeneity and and in
biology with a whole new lens
in 2019 nature methods selected single
cell multiomics as the method of the
year and so
what we are talking about here is how we
can start extracting different layers of
information from the same cell so we can
go beyond gene expression and we can
start looking at things like epigenetics
uh proteins and and other type of
modalities simultaneously from the same
cell
and last year again nature method
selected spatial gene expression as the
method of the year and this is a
revolutionary type of analysis where we
are actually extracting this information
directly from tissues so we don't do
study special context which could be
extremely important when we for example
are asking questions about uh car t
cells trafficking the tumor
microenvironment
so we see that single cell is very
complementary to special technologies um
of course the focus today is gonna be
single cell but i thought i will show
you basically an overview of what has
happened in the field in in recent years
so at the next we're really moving away
from legacy tools like bulk uh ball has
been instrumental to help us address
different issues in biology
but it's it has limitations and and
especially in areas such as cell therapy
where we have a lot of heterogeneity and
we have a product that is actually
evolving over time
so with bulk what we get is an average
and that average it's basically a bias
towards the most common cell type in our
sample so we can appreciate the amount
of information we are leaving on the
table just because we don't have the
resolution to gather this information in
a more specific way
with single cell we can extract
information from each cell in that
sample so we get something like we see
here where each dot or circle represents
a cell and then we can start coloring
these dots or cells based on their
phenotypes if we are looking at genes
being expressed at open bridges of
chromatin a protein so a combination of
all of these different modalities so we
can have a combination of on super
biased clustering basically let the data
tell us what type of clusters we have
but we can add that to that annotations
with canonical markers to actually find
the specific cell types or even cell
states in our cell in our sample
and then with spatial as we mentioned
before this is something that we are
also developing at the next so we have
for single cell we have our chromium
platform and for spatial we have our
vision platform where we can look at
this gene expression or even proteins
from the tissues directly and what we
see is that uh research groups are
actually using these platforms in a
complementary fashion so so they can
extract as much information as possible
uh from their uh in their projects
and in terms of publications at 10x we
really keep a close eye on what people
are doing with this tool and the best
way to do that is just looking at the
work that is being published
so we are over 200 publications right
now and of course this is very exciting
for us at the next but it's also a great
resource for i think most people in this
school to really see how these
technologies are being used to tackle
questions that are similar to yours
so we see that as an inspiration really
you see how this could be used in
innovative ways but also it can be very
practical so we see resources here
associated with sample preparation for
single set experiments all the way to
software tools to really get into the
data and the story behind the data so
this is a great resource that we have uh
for all these different areas of future
the research and and the good thing is
that single subject expression has been
with us for for a long time now so
we have i i feel an example for almost
every type of question at this point
in terms of the tools that we offer at
tanac so we really wanted to offer a
streamlined workflow for our different
solutions so we have instruments we also
have reagents and i wanted to mention
here the software piece so we offer
software that are free of cost and these
include two different
type of tools one is is pipelines so we
really can process that data that comes
from the sequencer so we don't have to
basically start looking and and putting
together up together a pipeline but
these pipelines are ready for you to use
so you can process that those raw files
from the sequencer and then you can end
up with a visualization tool which we
offer as well
so we actually see here in the right and
a screenshot of one of those
visualization tools that we can use to
basically visualize assess and and run
different type of analysis from our
samples
and at the next we have an innovation
engine um that keeps evolving and this
evolves based on the ask from different
researchers we work with so we have
different options and and what we do
attentively is to connect with
researchers to help them find the best
tool for their scientific question today
we're going to focus on a number of
those solutions um we are going to see
the use of single-sergeant expressions
so this is one of our first products uh
we are on version three and and we're
gonna see how we can use this to assess
single cells extract the whole
transcriptome of these cells but we can
also have a targeted lens when we work
with a specific
gene panel associated with our
scientific questions or experimental
design
we also are going to talk about a single
cell immune profiling and this is
extremely relevant in cell therapy of
course when we are looking at immune
response and we are trying to really
re-engineer some of these immune cells
so this solution allows not only to
recover gene expression full
transcriptome or targeted but also allow
us to get the these are this t-cell
receptors from those cells so the key
part is that with this information we
can start tracking clones we can really
follow them over them and see how they
are expanding and what what's the
persistent persistence of this specific
um quantity
and we are also going to see really
briefly and talk really briefly about
our new single cell multiple assay where
we can extract information from gene
expression together with epigenetics
looking at open regions of chromatin so
we can think about this too long how we
can visualize these switches that are
programming the genes that are being
expressed and could help us explain all
these different phenotypes that we see
with the cells
so we are here to talk specifically
about cell therapy research and um
emily's story is really a testament of
of how impactful these technologies
could be to help patients
emily was one of the first humans and
the first child to have access to an
experimental treatment at the time for
her b-cell accusing fulvastic leukemia
so kimraya is now an approved
cardiotherapy the first one approved by
the fda and we really hope to see more
of these examples in the future but we
also know that there are fundamental
questions we have to address
to
to make this a reality
and here i want to show you just a few
examples that we can think of on the
type of questions fundamental questions
we have to tackle to really have
successful uh cell therapies
so we i'm just going to mention a few of
the ones we have here in terms of tumor
heterogeneity
we have a lot of questions around
antigens and antigen development and of
course of tissue toxicities that we see
with some of these therapies
when we're thinking about expansion and
persistence of these cells we also can
think about how we can um
have a lot of heterogeneity in the
product so we can actually exploit these
to understand better those products and
start predicting what's going to happen
to patients after we make infusions of
these products
and then we can also think about the
insertions and the edits that we're
making to these cells and the impact
this has directly on the phenotypes and
the expansion of these cells in the
tumor microenvironment so all these
different questions that we still need
to resolve
but now we have tools that could allow
us to tackle some of those in a in a
very unbiased and scalable fashion
so here i'm going to give you different
flavors on how we've seen this
technology is being used in cell therapy
research
so we have the high throughput aspect
and we touched on this before on how
it's not all about just looking at
single cells and looking at their
modalities their molecules but also
doing this a scale where we can do this
for
hundreds of thousands even millions of
cells in one experiment so this could be
extremely powerful to discovery t cell
enhancing targets
and then of course we have the aspect of
multiomic characterization so as we
mentioned before we can go beyond gene
expression we can actually use look at
the modifications that we're doing to
these cells we can look at tc t-cell
receptors we can look at even proteins
or multi or
epigenetic characteristics of these
cells and in some cases we can make
these measurements simultaneously and we
are going to see examples on how this is
being used
in different points of development in
cell therapy
we of course can exploit that
information to identify cell states and
cell types and so we can use this
information to uncover suppressors or
activators that are cell type specific
in the tumor microenvironment
another aspect that we can explore is
how we can start tracking this quantum
behavior and for this is very critical
to have this receptor information at a
single cell scale so we can actually see
these clones and start linking
phenotypes of these clones with their
behavior
we can start using these tools to
distinguish between carb positive or
transgenic tcr
cells
from endogenous t cells
and another example here will be using
unbiased gene expression detection
to look at expression of antigens in
unexpected places or cell populations
and again we're going to see examples on
how that's being used
in the research
so i'm going to walk you through these
examples with with this type of
structure going from target discovery
to characterization of the infusion
product then we're gonna see examples uh
in response monitoring and we're gonna
finish with with one example in
resistance profiling so the idea here is
that we give you a tour of all these
different publications that we've seen
in these different areas to advance our
cell therapies
so starting with target discovery there
are so many different directions that we
can take here but i want to focus on
these two key questions related to
target screening and functional
screening
so when we think about functional
screening we could think about an
experiment where we use the single
surgeon expression solution from the max
and then pair that uh gene expression
profiles from these cells together with
dna amplicons for specific modifications
we've done to those cells so with this
information we have paired libraries
where we can actually look at the
phenotypes and the modifications we are
doing to those cells to see the direct
link between those modifications and the
effects they have on those cells
and so this is what this this group from
ucsf and alexa martin's alex martin's
lab did
so they developed a new a new functional
screening tool called pull knocking
sequencing or pocky sick
and the idea here is that you start with
a pool of knocking so they started with
with 36 different constructs
that you think will modulate t-cell
functions so for example some of those
will use over-expression of genes
associated with cell thickness or
activation
and then you take these constructs and
use them to modify a library of t cells
the next step is to apply selective
pressures that mimic the environment
that these cells are going to embrace in
the tumor microenvironment when there
are traffic in there
and then we use those cells with these
modifications after these selective
pressures to use the single cell gene
expression profiling and in this case
they extracted the libraries for gene
expression but they also use amplicon
sequencing of these knocking constructs
to have that paired information
what is the effect of these specific
modifications in the phenotypes of of
these cells
so one benefit of this approach is that
we can start looking at the type of
modifications these cells have
so we can have cells with one uh single
construct but we can also have cells
with multiple modifications so we can
deconvolute that and really observe the
type of modifications if it is one or if
it is a combination of more than one
modification
and the most exciting part of course is
looking at the phenotype of those cells
so what's happening with those cells in
vitro or in vivo and this is what this
group uh was looking at
so they found that a specific type of
constructs that were modified um or that
were synthetic receptors at egf br br2
lead to an increase in t-cell abundance
in solid tumors but they also induce
different cell states
one particular construct 41 bb
actually showed to promote accumulation
of cells expressing key effector
cytokine genes that will enhance
tumor clearance so very exciting finding
and a very um innovative approach to
really look at this uh question in terms
of discovering and and and doing
targeted screens
the next example i want to show you
still on target discovery has a totally
different lens and and it's more focused
on target screening
so here we could think about using our
single sodium expression or even single
selenium profiling solutions
to start looking at single cell atlases
and see at the expression of specific
antigens in places that we might not
expect them to see being expressed and
so we can use this type of information
to understand and and really find the
roots of of uh of tissue toxicities that
we find with some of these therapies
so this is what this group uh from upenn
and stanford led by carl june avery
posey and sat passy and others these
they were focusing on cd19 directed car
t cells we know that these therapies
have shown
studying
efficacy in hematological b cell
malignancies but we also know that we
have major side effects associated with
neurotoxicities which could be lethal
like most in most cases
so the hypothesis from this group was
that perhaps there is a population of
cells in the brain expressing the cd19
markers
and so some people were skeptical about
this hypothesis but they went on they
extracted data from single-sergeant
expression databases focusing on
prefrontal cortex cells they excluded
neuronal and edisor clusters from their
analysis
and to their surprise they found a very
rare cell type called parasites
expressing this cd19 marker
so they wanted to make sure this was not
an artifact so they did different
subsequential testing one of those was
to look at the expression of other type
of b-cell markers so they look at the
expression of cd79a
they found it in b cells but they didn't
see this marker in parasites in the
brain
confirming that in fact there is a
population in the brain that is
expressed in the cd 19 a marker being
these parasites um cells
one question they had of course is a
very comprehensive paper but they also
wanted to look at what happens in other
organs because we have parasites in the
lung we have it in the kidney but we
don't see toxicities in these organs
when we have 50 19 directed cardi cells
therapy
so here we see the expression of cd19 in
parasites in the brain and in the lung
and in this green box we see that the
expression of cd19 is very specific for
parasites in the brain but we don't see
it in the lung
one potential explanation is the
developmental pathways of these cells so
we know that parasites in the brain
actually derive from different enviro
embryonic regions compared to those in
the lungs so this could explain the diff
different epigenetic pathways that they
go through to end up with the expression
of sitting in the brain but not in the
law
and so we can think about how this this
type of groundwork could be expanded
beyond these cd18 directed uh therapies
and and one um comment from avery posey
and other has been how we single cell we
really are able for the first time to
identify this type of cell at this type
of rare event this small proportion of
cells that well most people were not
expecting to see in the brain but it
really comes down to the resolution that
we have um and the power that that that
these technologies can allow us to have
to assess heterogeneity
so as i mentioned before we can think
about how we could use this to de-risk
cell therapy in terms of antigen
discovery so we saw this example on how
we can use single cells to identify of
target toxicities but we could also
think about how we can use this to
de-risk existing targets we have and i
think something that is very very
exciting is how we can think about the
next generation of antigens in the
timeline or that we are discovering and
how we can use this baseline information
to really build from there and start
generating targets that are safer for
patients
moving on to the next aspect of
development i want to show you examples
on uh related to characterization of the
infusion product so here we can ask
questions about how this infusion
product contributes to poor expansion of
persistence and even toxicities of of
these therapies
and so here we can start combining for
example information from the single cell
immune profiling aspect together with
clinical features to really see the
impact of these products their
heterogeneity in um in in the effects in
patients and their response
so this work from michael green as md
anderson did that so they took the
leftovers from infusion products that
were infused to 24 patients um these are
cd19
targeted cardi treatment and then they
used a single cell approach looking at
global transfusion
t-cell receptor frequency and they also
used a targeted approach so for this
they develop a panel of about 200 genes
associated with immune response toxicity
signatures and of course also car
expression
and then they compare that data with
clinical parameters so their goal here
was to assess
is there a connection between the
characteristics of this product and the
responses we see in patients
and they found that they were there was
the web connections so we see in blue
the the data from patients that
responded to treatment and he read those
patients that had food response or
progressive disease so we see in blue
these patients that progress we see
enrichment for memory cd4 and cd8 cells
and patients with progressive disease we
see enrichment for uh exhausted uh
phenotypes
so just to remember here that this is
the infusion product so this is
characterizing this product before they
could go into patients could give us a
good overview and potentially predict
what the response is going to be
and this is another way to look at this
data so you will see that with single
cell you are gathering a lot of
information and so there are different
ways to really extract stigmas from from
these datasets so here we see different
clusters that were found in in the
infusion products and how this relates
to different patient response so we see
that cluster one was highly expressed in
patients that had a progressive disease
and here the genes that we see the
signatures we see in the genes expressed
is related to exhaustion and dysfunction
cluster four
it's highly expressed in patients that
responded to treatment and then the
signatures we hear we see here in the
transcriptome are related to central
memory
another interesting and really
surprising finding here was at the
presence of a monocyte-like trans
transcriptional signature in this
infusion product
and and and the key part here is that
they found an association between the
presence of these monocyte-like cells
with neurotoxicity syndrome so
the the preva the the
frequency of these uh cells with
monocyte like signatures were very very
rare
but again we see how powerful these
technologies could be to find these
great events
tricky to find tricky to expect but that
of course will have and we see
association with with patient response
moving on to our third area in in terms
of response monitoring we can start
looking at these tools and see how we
can use them to see at the evolution of
the infusion product in vivo
and so here we have an example where we
actually
saw the use of single cell immune
profiling so we can look at the gene
expression this phenotype of cells
together with vdj sequences
and then start looking at these
chronotypes over time
so this work uh from the fred hutch uh
look at that really looking at the
clonal dynamics of car t-cells uh from
patients over time and so they started
with a bulk assessment of these cardi
clones
and they notice different patterns in
terms of transcriptional profiles and
and and evolution of these clones but
they couldn't come up with a specific
association in terms of which type of
clones are the ones being expanded and
changing over time so this is why they
went
to a single cell approach using the
single cell immune profiling and they
were able to
reveal different transcriptional
profiles at different times
during the ip product at
characterization point of the ib product
early late and very late after infusion
so we see that represented here in these
different colors
and of course we can start looking at
the specific signals that are expressed
at these different time points so we see
that early on uh there is an enrichment
of activation and effector response in
these cells
but as i mentioned the key part here is
that how we can use the quantum
information to see the type of cons are
actually driving these
responses
so they use
using the single cell
data they
focus on the infusion product and then
identify four different clusters that we
see here in different colors
so cluster two showed a high expression
of cytotoxic genes and close uh cluster
four show enrichment of proliferation
associated genes
cluster three on the other hand show
enrichment for genes associated with
pre-apoptosis
so by looking at these quantum
information based on paired tcr
sequencing we can look at those cones
and then we can look at the gene
expression and then identify what are
the clones that are being expanded it's
being expanded driving these signatures
so we see that there is a progressive
increase over time
of uh clusters of clones that belong to
cluster two and 4 that we saw had
signatures of cytotoxic and
proliferation-associated genes
so it really shows how we can use this
information to not only track these
clones over time but really see their
phenotypes and their responses
the same a similar type of um
idea was used for the first in human
crispr trial
uh where um we saw four different edits
uh from these t cells that were being
infused back to patients
so these different ethics included
changes to the tcr alpha and beta mpd
genes and also the introduction of an
engineered dc are
recognizing tumor antigen the tumor
antigen nyso1
so this group used uh the single cell uh
gene expression platform um
and and then captured the gene
expressions but also the modifications
that the cell had so we saw this during
a functional screening phase but of
course we see it now again in vivo
so as we saw before with this type of
analysis we can start looking at the
specific modifications the cells are
going to have so some of these cells are
going to have one two three or four of
those modifications in different type of
combinations so we can actually look at
that that specific data and all these
different combinations
and so they really wanted to know what
happens to these different mutations
over time in patients so then we see for
example here um at the time of the
infusion 10 days and 113 days after
infusion and the differences between the
persistence of these different mutations
so for the tcr a
mutation and nyso we see that there is
persistence over time
but for pd1 mutations these tend to
become depleted
and then we can also look at the
phenotype of these cells so in this case
we're focusing on the nyso type of
mutations and what we see is that these
cells actually adopt a memory-like
phenotype in this patient
so very promising aspect of this
technology and of course uh this is
going to give us a root and an aroma for
the next generation of cell therapies
and the last
type of example is associated with
resistance profiling so we can think
about a different aspect we haven't
explored in terms of examples before and
it's looking at the epigenetic factors
that are actually driving these
different phenotypes that are uh wanted
and those that are unwanted in this case
exostation and dysfunctional t cells of
course are stereotypes that we want to
avoid so what are the switches that
actually are programming this type of
unwanted phenotypes and and these to set
the start to basically develop ideas to
um avoid them
so in this example we're going to see
the use of single cells gene expression
to actually identify these transcription
factors associated with extra station
but we could think about also using uh
something like the single cell multim
where we actually are capturing not only
the genes that are being expressed but
also the open regions of chromatin so we
can visualize this and start looking at
specific repressors of or enhancers of
this gene expression program
so going back to our example here this
come from rachel lin's uh team at
stanford and so they were really
focusing on understanding the regulators
of cartier actual station so we know
this is a barrier for the success of
these type of therapies so they created
a model in which healthy t cells were
driven to exostation
by the expression of tonically signaling
car
and then they of course explore all
these different transcription factors
that were driving these expression
profiles associated with exostation
so one particular one uh called c june
showed to be very promising in terms of
explaining this type of phenotypes they
found that when c unit is overexpressed
this renders cartesia resistant to
exhaustion so it gives really
interesting opportunities in the future
to explore this particular
transition factor further
and and i want to finish this example
section section uh with what's happening
currently what how are these two tools
being used and then i'm gonna give you
one example of that
uh so this is work from an ibanovic
attendant in collaboration with
christine brown from the city of hope
and they are using a small theomic and
multi-tissue profile profiling of car t
for glioblastoma
and so they are using a combination of
different tissue and sample types they
are collecting from patients um
including pvmcs uh tumor samples csf
together with the cardi product and then
they are applying a single sample
geometry approach so they are planning
to use the single cell multi-ohm
solution um the single cell immune
profiling together with a single sardine
expression
and they are also adding these spatial
aspect to their tissues so really look
at where these genes are being expressed
in the tissues directly and start asking
questions about what happens when these
cells are actually trafficking in the
tumor microenvironment
and i want to finish with our last
section on on getting started with a
single cell and special solution so this
is going to be short it's not
comprehensive it's just going to be an
overview to get you thinking about these
experiments um but just before i go
there if if you have any questions ideas
on where to start with your single cell
experiment um wherever you are we have a
10x local team ready to to talk with you
and really help you address these
experimental design questions that could
be very important when you start
thinking about single cell
so as i mentioned before we have an
innovation engine behind our solutions
so different options that can help you
tackle your question in a very specific
way
so the first step will be really looking
at what's my goal and what's the way the
best way to get there
so we have a different type of options
and and if you're thinking about more
geomics there are different ways to get
more genomic information but again it's
it's really based on your scientific
question and what you want to get out of
it
so the first step is selecting that
solution for your question
and then the next step is of course
thinking about all these different steps
that you will go through when you are
doing a single cell experiment so
everything starts with your sample which
is the input we see in the last so
getting that sample ready and again this
could be blood it could be cell lines it
could be tumor tissue so there's a lot
of variation in terms of the samples
that are run with our instruments so
really thinking about the best protocols
to bring that sample to the experiment
is is going to set you to success the
great thing here is that we have so much
data in terms of what works and what
doesn't work for a cell suspension
generation so we have a lot of resources
that can help you have a really nice
suspension for your experiment
the next step is library creation so
here we're actually using our single
cell
solutions and reagents that we selected
in the previous step and then you end up
with uh libraries so those libraries are
going to have the single cell
information of your molecules because
they're going to be barcoded they're
going to have
your cell address and then we are going
to be able to identify basically where
they came from
so the sequencing steps uh can happen on
illumina platform so our libraries are
compatible with lumia platform and we
have recommendations for all these
different sequencing requirements for
each um solution that we have and then
the last step is that analysis and
visualization and i mentioned this
before on how with connect you have
access to pipelines but also
visualization tools that are open and
free of cost so with the pipelines you
can process that data from the sequencer
and then get output files that you can
use in our visualization tool the loop
browser or you can use a third-party
tools as well which we have a lot which
is a great thing to have right now with
single cell
and i just want to briefly show you
what the the worst looks like for a for
a spatial experiment with lithium so
here of course the input is different
because we're working with with tissues
so you will
uh you will work with uh cryo sectioning
of your tissue you will have a a special
set of slides that are basically uh
these film is a set of spatial slides
that allows to capture these molecular
information directly from tissues but we
also capture the morphology and this
could be based on hne or
immunofluorescence so you choose and the
same
tissue section that you stain goes
through library creation and then those
libraries are sequencing and then we
have data processing and visualization
tools so those later stages are actually
similar to our single cell but of course
the samples are totally different so
different perspectives on on on your
samples and so we have a number of
resources uh we have as i mentioned so
many publications we also have
demonstrated protocols in house and
there are customer developed protocols
that are extremely valuable um for
different type of samples uh the last
piece and i think one of the most
important ones is the the supporting
that we have so always ready to answer
your questions which can be very
specific so so please get in touch if
you want to learn more
and i'm gonna thank you everyone for
attending um i'm happy to get uh take
any questions that you might have
thank you dr sores for that informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of this webinar and if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on the ask a question
box
so let's get started
we already have some great questions
coming in dr suarez
our first question from an audience
member is what has been one of the most
surprising findings in cell therapy
research when applying a single cell
lens to characterizing cellular products
wow that's an interesting question
um i think we we saw a couple of those
examples uh today i think i'm gonna pick
um
two of the examples we saw
one related to target discovery and the
other one in terms of characterization
of the infusion products so we saw
interrogative screening um at this group
led by anthocy and others finding
the expression of cd19
in in a rare cell type in the brain
something that we were not really
expecting we knew we had neurotoxicities
when we were thinking about acidity
directed car therapies
but um using single cell and and it's
again it's it's really looking at the
scale of these technologies because
finding these rare events it's it's not
easy if you don't have the capacity to
really expand this to
tend to
hundreds of thousands of cells at a time
so really exploiting these cell atlases
they were able to find a specific cell
population expressing this marker and
and i think the most exciting part is
how we can think about a similar
approach to assess other type of
antigens and most importantly to really
develop the next generation of antigens
that could be safer
because we could avoid some of these
off-target and of tissue toxicities and
then the second one the second example
we saw was more related to the
characterization of the infusion product
so uh um
this work from michael green's uh
showing the presence of a monocyte-like
population in in the infusion product of
a curry product was very surprising so
we can start thinking on where this is
going to take us when we started
actually using these type of
technologies uh in in a broader context
and so i think the theme of these two
examples and the other examples we've
seen is heterogeneity right we're
working with uh cell therapies we we're
expecting heterogeneity and now we have
the tools to address it and to explore
it so we can use it in our advantage to
address these relative questions with
the antigens we have but of course think
about how we can use them to redesign
future ones
thank you so much now are frozen tissue
samples compatible with a single cell
rna sequencing
yeah so i mean it's an important
question in terms of how we can prepare
samples for these type of analysis
frozen tissue it is compatible and we
have option in terms of how we can get
into a cell suspension or cell
or single nuclei suspension um so of
course the the ideal situation is that
we have fresh tissues but we know that
in a clinical setting this might not be
possible
so there are ways to preserve those
tissues if you have the option to bring
those tissues to cell suspension and add
a cryopreservant like dmso that's that
would be ideal
but if your tissues are already frozen
there are protocols that could help us
get to nuclei which in those cases would
be the ideal type of protocol to use and
we see that when we think about nuclei
this is a very
well adopted workflow in in those cases
where we have protein tissue so yeah
we're going to have different ways on
how these tissues are preserved if you
are able to to talk about the logistics
of acquiring these tissues if you are in
the designing stage of your experiment i
think bringing um your the next
local team or
or people that are familiar with the
technology will be extremely useful so
you design that collection and
and that processing of tissues but if
that's if the tissues are there and that
didn't happen before definitely there
are options for different type of
preservation methods
thank you so much dr soares and i want
to thank again our audience for these
great questions coming in
can i sort my cells prior to running
through the 10x single cell assay
yes absolutely so uh sorting is
compatible with nx and and
widely used so a lot of the examples we
saw today actually sorted themselves
especially when we are looking at a
specific cell population that we want to
explore um that's the best option if
you're looking at single selling in
profiling that should be your route
you're really sorting and reaching for a
specific cell population and then going
from there
um that's not required though so if
you're looking at basically
heterogeneity and then just looking at
all these different cell types perhaps
in the tumor microenvironment and you
really want to assess what's happening
there um sorting is not necessarily
required we also know that some people
store to really
clean their cell suspension so that's
also an option but there are also
different ways to increase viability of
your cell suspension so yeah it's
compatible uh but you you have options
in terms of how you process your samples
before it's next
thank you so much now our next audience
member wants to know why do i have to
use nuclei with a multi-ohm assay
right yeah so that multi you must say
for those that are not familiar we
launched this product late last year
and and we are very excited about it i
think a lot of the researchers we're
working with are are very exciting and
keen to start with this solution it
allows us to capture not only gene
expression but also open regions of
chromatin directly from the same cells
and yes the input is nuclei because we
are after the chromatin inside the
nucleus so we we found that the best way
to do that to access that content is by
starting with nuclei one reason is that
we want to avoid that mitochondrial dna
that we have in cells so by removing the
cell and just working with the nuclei it
gives gives us a better chance to do
that and and and we have optimized
protocols to bring um cells to nuclear
suspension and we also have protocols
for different uh
sample types so we have three protocols
one for pncs and cell lines we have
another one for
tissues that are easy to disassociate
like embryonic tissue for example and
then another protocol for hard to
disassociate tissue so depending on your
sample we we might have a protocol for
you and so
uh there are options and and yeah the
reason for nuclei just to get that uh
chromatin accessibility information in a
most efficient way
dr saurus thank you so much we have time
for one more question
where do you see single cell having the
biggest impact in the field
wow yeah i think um
there is a lot of excitement about
motherhood
and and really
how these different modalities can help
us understand these cells in a better
way from a phenotypic perspective but
also from an evolutionary perspective
like how these clones are changing over
time and how we can drive some of those
changes by looking at these different
modalities simultaneously
and i mean this is in terms of
technologies the single asylum theory
aspect and even including the spatial
context where you could think it could
be another modality that you could add
to your map of cells and then in terms
of areas of research i think there is a
lot of interest to on looking at um the
immune response of patients before they
go to treatment so we know that usually
patients that go through a cell therapy
option have gone through different
license therapies before that
chemotherapies that are altering um
these immune profiling um in terms of
their endogenous immune system so i
think there is a lot of interest in
understanding that
initial or post treatment stage before
they go into cell therapy and then see
how we can put all these viables
together if we are working on an
autologous type of approach
or even just looking at ex predicting on
how these therapies are going to um
evolve and change within those patients
so i think that's an interesting
research area but as we saw today there
are so many different type of
applications so i'm sure we're going to
see a lot of developments in the future
dr soares thank you again for your time
today for your presentation and for your
important research and before we go i
want to thank our audience members for
joining us as well and for their
interesting questions and a reminder
this webcast will now be available on
demand through april of 2022
we hope you enjoyed this event thank you
and have a great day bye bye everyone